hello and welcome to Tech deals which
rx560 graphics card should you buy
comparison video we are testing eight
different graphics cards today yes there
will be benchmarks later in the video
and yes there are time stamps down in
the video description below if you'd
like to skip around and jump to a
specific spot we are answering four
questions today the first is should you
buy an RX 560 at all the second which
560 should you buy if you decide to buy
one the third question is should you buy
the 2 gbyte or 4 GB card and finally the
last question kind of a bonus question
how about the rx550 which is the baby
brother to these cards now there are
eight cards on the desk you will see all
eight of them tested later in this video
seven of these cards are RX 560s one of
them this assus right here is an RX
550 now two of the 560 cards are 4 GB
one of these identical Sapphire pulses
is 4 GB the other is two and then this m
MSI arrow down here is also a 4 GB card
the others are 2 GB and you'll see them
all in the same games in just a minute
now the first question is should you buy
an RX 560 at all if you'd like to learn
more about the architecture free sync
support radon chill and some other
excellent features of these cards check
out my launch review of The 500 series
linked down in the video description
below instead I'm going to talk
primarily about the end user experience
and who should buy this card Esports
Gamers who are looking for a premium
card to play any Esports game or casual
game at 1080p at great performance
League of Legends Counter-Strike Global
Offensive Dota 2 OverWatch World of
Tanks World of Warships games like that
will play beautifully on an rx560 at
1080p High detail High refresh rate you
don't have to spend any more than $100
to $150 to play those sorts of games AAA
games yes it will play those as well but
not necessarily at higher Ultra detail
I'm going to show you some of those
benchmarks later in the video but if
you're okay to turn the graphic detail
down or if maybe you run on a 720p or
900p monitor instead of a 1080p it's
still a reasonable choice for somebody
who's not Ultra serious about those
games now certainly if you want to play
Battlefield 1 at 1080p at Ultra detail
you will need something faster than this
an RX 580 or a GTX 1060 would be a much
better choice for that sort of game Mass
Effect Andromeda Ghost Recon wildlands
if you want to play at high very high or
Ultra detail at 1080p again you'll need
more graphics card but it will play
those games at lower detail settings
Grand Theft Auto 5 high detail very
playable I'm going to show you that here
in a minute so the person who should buy
an rx560 is somebody who wants to be
able to play all current games on the
market who's willing to be flexible with
the detail settings on AAA gaming titles
and who doesn't want to spend too much
money these cards are very low power
draw they'll fit into most computers and
frankly for the average game gamer they
really are all that you need as you'll
see from the benchmarks in just a minute
the next question is which rx560 should
you buy now there's several factors to
consider brand and appearance is one but
those are largely personally subjective
whether you like Sapphire assus MSI
gigabyte Etc now there are other
objective factors to consider size and
fit for example do you have longer cards
such as the ones on the top here and
then you have shorter cards such as the
ones I put in the front if you have a
smaller computer with maybe a mini tower
desktop or a smaller form factor machine
you may need to buy the smaller cards in
order to get them to fit into your
computer beyond the physical size you
have temperature and noise now the cards
on the top were placed there for a
reason they are a little bit cooler and
a little bit quieter than the cards in
the front are it's not a dramatic
difference but it is noticeable and I
did notice it while I was testing the
cards in the front are a little bit
louder and do seem to run a little bit
warmer than the cards in in the back now
these are subjective opinions of me
testing all of these cards back to back
not done in a sound isolation chamber
which I don't have but if you are
concerned about noise I would recommend
going with one of the cards on the top
rather than ones in the front if they
will fit into your machine another very
important factor to consider is power
connectors the two sapphire pulse the
vision Tech and the gigabyte card all
require a six pin PCI Express power
connector from your power supply the
power color the MSI arrow and the Asus
do not if you have an older machine that
does not have a six- pin PCI Express
power connector those three cards can be
very helpful because they do not require
a six pin PCI Express power connector I
will make one cautionary statement here
if you have a 5-year-old Dell Optiplex
the older business class machines not
consumer the Inspiron and vros are
generally fine but the Opti plux
machines are known to not provide enough
power on the PC
Express slot to run cards that don't use
a six pin connector those machines you'd
be better off replacing the power supply
and getting a card with the power
connector consumer machines are fine
newer machines are fine but I've
reviewed in past videos those Dell
Optiplex machines quite a bit and I want
to make you aware that they only provide
35 Watts instead of 75 Watts on that PCI
Express slot and I have had problems
putting the non-pci express power
connector Cards into the older Dell uh
business class machines such as the
Optiplex one further point on the cards
with and without the PCI Express power
connector the outof the-box clock speeds
are higher on the card such as the
sapphire pulse that have that connector
and they can be overclocked further
manually now all of these cards could be
overclocked but the ones without the
power connector will be limited to power
consumption due to the fact that they
have to pull all of their power out of
the PCI Express lot if manual
overclocking if getting the most out of
your available card purchase is
important to you then buy one of the
cards with the six pin connector on it
the third question is should you buy a 2
GB or 4 GB version of the rx560 in my
opinion the 2 GB is the deal there are
two sapphire pulse cards here they are
identical in all respects except the
onboard vram one has 2 GB one has 4 GB
now there are games such as Ghost Recon
Wildland I'll show you in The Benchmark
here in a minute that will use more than
2 GB of vram and I'll show you that in
the Benchmark but watch the frame rates
and look at the results it isn't as
different as you might think even when
the game is using nearly 3 GB of vam now
if you're still not persuaded by that
and you still want to buy the 4 GB card
4 future proofing how much would I spend
no more than $20 over the price of a 2
GB card so if the 2 GB card that you
want to buy is
$110 then I wouldn't spend more than
$130 for the 4 gigb card your opinion
May differ but in my mind that's all the
extra vram is worth the reality is I
think most people are best off with the
2 GB versions of the
rx560 and the fourth question we're
looking at today is is it worth buying
the
rx550 if gaming is your primary interest
no it really isn't the price difference
between an rx550 and an rx560 is too
small to justify the performance
difference now the rx550 has half of the
compute power of the 560 it isn't quite
half of the actual performance in the
real world due to the fact that doubling
your Shader or compute account never
quite doubles your actual real world
performance but the reality is there is
a massive gap between the 550s and the
560 I'm going to show you that and
include that in the benchmarks in just a
minute the RX 550 which is reviewed
Linked In the description below if you
want to see the Standalone review is
primarily aimed at home theater PCS and
non-gaming tasks it's a video card for
somebody who needs a modern graphics
card with an HDMI 2.0 port with HDR
support radon chill and some other
Technologies but gaming is not your
primary focus that's really where that
card is aimed so if you want to play
games get a 560 if you don't want to
play games and you simply need say an
HDMI 2.0 port to connect to a 4K
television or monitor the rx550 fits the
bill very well now before we get to the
benchmarks let me explain the test setup
and how I have things configured for the
results you're about to see the CPU that
we're testing on today is amd's newly
launched ryzen 3 1300x CPU it is a four
core four thread CPU very similar to
Intel's I5 chips and in fact if you have
a recent I5 such as an i56500 or 7500
it's almost identical in performance to
those it has a base clock speed of 3.5
GHz and a maximum xfr automatic
overclocking speed to 3.9 we are running
at those outof theeb boox speeds there
is no manual overclocking going on on
that chip that chip is installed in the
assus b350 prime $89 motherboard and
we're using the AMD stock cooler we have
16 GB of Corsair Vengeance lpx ddr4 300
RAM installed running at ddr4
2933 all of the games were tested at
1080p full HD resolution and recorded on
my external Elgato hd60s capture card no
performance loss whatsoever for
capturing the video you're about to see
but the video you're about to see is
from the actual benchmarks that you'll
see in the charts at the end of this
video that Elgato hd60s is wonderful for
this kind of benchmarking because it
does not require using any software on
the test machine the computer doesn't
even know it was being recorded MSI
After Burner is used to provide the
real-time performance numbers you'll see
in green on the screen and fraps was
used for some but not all of the
benchmarking some of the games such as
rise of the Tomb Raider direct X12 were
recorded using their games built-in
benchmarks and with that out of the way
let's take a look at some benchmarks now
first up we're we're going to look at
three Esports or casual gaming titles
Counterstrike Global Offensive League of
Legends OverWatch and World of Tanks now
each of these four games is only being
tested on one card there's really no
reason to test it on all the cards it
takes a long time and the results are
spectacular now if you look at the
real-time frame rate you'll see that
Counter-Strike Global Offensive in the
upper leftand corner is running over 150
frames per second and we are set at high
detail in fact if you look at the top
line the rx560 line you will notice that
it is often not at 100% usage it is at
times but at the moment it's dipping
down there's 92% it dipped down to 84% a
second ago there are times when the
ryzen 3300x is actually bottlenecking a
$110 graphics card now if you want 250
frames per second you could always buy
an rx570 or you could turn the detail
down as I said I manually set all the
detail settings to high this game and
League of Legends are probably the two
big exceptions for the rx550 card which
I talked about earlier before at either
medium or high detail an rx550 would
actually run Counter-Strike Global
Offensive or League of Legends at over
100 frames per second but those are the
exception the other games won't
necessarily do that now coming down to
the bottom we have OverWatch on the
bottom leftand corner and World of Tanks
on the bottom right hand corner now
OverWatch is being run at high detail
World of Tanks is being run at maximum
detail what this shows you is what
happens when you take a relatively
casual game and crank the detail to the
max at least in world of Tank's case
you'll notice that the frame rate is
below 100 frames per second you could
get that over 100 frames a second by
lowering it down to medium or high
detail instead of having it cranked to
maximum with fulls screen antialising
turned on likewise if you want to turn
the detail from high up to ultra you'll
still get over 60 frames per second on
the rx560 on OverWatch we're currently
getting about 100 frames per second at
high detail you can see our vram usage
is just over 1300 megabytes no issue for
this 2 GB card and the performance is
wonderful of course if you're a
competitive player then you may turn the
detail down to low to get 150 plus
frames per second or maybe you really do
want an rx570 if 200 to 250 frames per
second is your goal now let me come back
up to League of Legends upper right hand
corner this is maximum detail we have
antialising turn turned on everything is
cranked to very high and as you can see
here we're currently running about 140
frames per second League of Legends is
of course a not very demanding game
it'll run on integrated Graphics pretty
well although not at this performance to
be sure one thing I'd like to point out
with League of Legends is that we are
actually CPU bound here you would need a
faster clocked CPU in order to run this
faster look at the percentage usage of
the graphics card our rx560 is actually
sitting around waiting for the CPU now
you may be saying wait a minute minute
the CPU is not at 100% how could we
possibly be bound by the CPU please keep
in mind 100% CPU usage would require all
four cores being fully utilized One Core
is 25% two cores is 50% because we're on
a four core fourth thread chip League of
Legends does not use four cores it will
never reach 100% usage on a chip like
this because the other cores are simply
idle it's using about 1 and a half at
the moment more than one but less than
two what this means is that in theory an
I3
7350k which is the unlocked I3 dual core
chip overclock to 5 GHz would actually
run this noticeably faster although for
a whole lot more money than this
processor costs High frame rates more
than anything else requires a ton of CPU
power and not necessarily more cores
more clock speed and more single core
performance in the case of many games so
it's worth keeping in mind that if 200
frames per second is your goal you need
a very powerful CPU in addition into
enough graphics performance now in my
opinion most people play games between
60 to 100 frames per second some people
have 144 HZ monitors and as you can see
from this video the
$130 ryzen
3300x at stock clock speeds out of the
box will easily run many of these games
not only at 144 frames per second but
sometimes faster we are over 200 frames
a second at the moment in Counterstrike
Global Offensive again OverWatch we are
graphics card lied turn the details down
a bit and you're going to get that 144
to 165 frames per second even on an
rx560 even on a ryzen
3300x you don't have to spend thousands
of dollars to play games at incredible
performance now that's enough of the
live gameplay why don't we take a look
at the Benchmark results the green bars
are the average frame rate
Counter-Strike Global Offensive High
detail 177 frames per second League of
Legends very high detail 100 143
OverWatch High detail 102 and World of
Tanks maximum detail with full screen
anti- aing turned on 79 frames per
second if you want to play casual and
Esports gaming titles the ones on the
list earlier in the video This is
actually all the graphics card you need
for 1080p gaming it really does the job
for $110 just fine even the minimum
frame rates are incredible now the red
bars are the 1% minimum and the blue
bars are the. 1% minimum briefly the red
bars represent the minimum frame rate
that you'll get 99% of the time it drops
the bottom 1% of the frames and
represents that as the minimum I believe
the red bars are the ones you should
focus on that's the playable number
that's the number you're going to see at
least 99% of the time now of course most
of the time it'll be much much faster
than that what it does is it removes the
temporary momentary blips that in a 10
or 20 minute gameplay session lasts for
maybe 10 frames and doesn't really
represent the true playability it was
just a momentary onetime hit hiccup the
blue bar takes that one decimal place
further
99.9% of the time and represents much
closer to a true minimum take a look at
our red bar numbers 112 frames per
second you'll get 99% of the time in
Counterstrike Global Offensive 100 in
League of Legends 80 in OverWatch and to
be sure 48 in World of Tanks I tested
World of Tanks at maxd tell to Simply
show what happens when you crank it to
the max in all honesty if you want to
play World of Tanks on this card turn it
down to high detail it'll still be
beautiful it'll still be incredible but
the performance numbers will come up
dramatically so that is for Esports or
casual gaming titles why don't we take a
look at Grand Theft Auto 5 now you are
looking at four of the eight cards right
here in just a minute you'll see the
other four cards I have labels on the
screen to make it easier for you to know
which card is which now MSI After Burner
is providing the realtime numbers in the
upper leftand corner of the screen and
these are as I said earlier being
recorded using my external Elgato hd60s
capture card so there is no performance
loss for having recorded this video the
runs that you are seeing here are in
fact the runs used for The Benchmark
numbers you'll see on the chart in just
a second but I do wish to caution you
regarding Grand Theft Auto 5 Grand Theft
Auto 5 is a very heavy CPU bound
Benchmark we are to some extent limited
to the ryzen 3 1300x CPU here you will
see a larger difference between these
eight cards on the other games I'm going
to show you in a minute now why am I
using a ryzen 3300 X why not just put in
a ryzen 5600 or ryzen 7700 or an i7
simple because I don't believe people
buying a $100 graphics cards tend to buy
such CPUs I'm trying to match this with
what I think is reasonable and we are
not CPU Limited in the other games at
least for the builtin Benchmark uh Ghost
Recon wildlands yes in the actual game
you're a bit bottlenecked but in The
Benchmark you're not and certainly in
the other games you're not I think a
$130 ryzen 3300x is all the CPU you
should consider having if you're buying
$110 graphics card and playing AAA games
is on your list now we are running in
high detail with full screen antialising
turned on one quick point and I will
address this again later in the video
with Ghost Recon I want to take a look
at the vram usage the MSI Arrow ITX card
in the bottom leand corner has 4 GB of
vram the other have two notice the vram
usage on that card is
2.75 GB notice the vram usage on the
other three cards is under 2 GB because
they are 2 GB cards take a look at the
real-time performance looks pretty even
to me now are there any compromises for
having 2 GB perhaps maybe not really in
all of the testing that I have done the
difference in playable performance
between the 2 GB and 4 GB cards is
virtually non-existent I fully recognize
that many people have looked at various
tests they've looked at the vram usage
numbers and they see the 2.8 gigs and go
oh no I I better get a card with more
vram not really you might be pleasantly
surprised at just how well the two G I
don't make the 2 gigabyte recommendation
lightly I really don't but it really is
all that you need now here are the next
four cards the top two cards are the
sapphire pulse now please note through
all the game tests you're about to see
these will be in the same order from
game to game so the 2 GB is in the upper
leftand corner and the 4 GB is in the
upper right hand corner again here you
can see the vram difference I would like
to point out the clock speed of those
two cards is identical 1300 mahz you'll
see the cards on the bottom are a
different speed of course the bottom
right is the Asus rx550 which is a
completely different card but that's a
subject for another minute if you look
in the upper right hand corner of each
run you will actually see the fraps
numbers up there that's because I'm not
benchmarking that section and now you
see them all go away The Benchmark
numbers you're going to see in a minute
are from this part of the Benchmark only
because the transition would totally
screw them up and trying to stitch four
separate Benchmark runs together is a
bit of a mess and some of those are
pretty short so The Benchmark numbers
you're going to see are this section
with the jet and the the truck running
through the city not the uh previous
portions you could see the real-time
numbers but the uh 1% minimum the. 1%
minimum and the average frame rate is
from this section right here now fraps
is being used for the performance
numbers for Grand Theft Auto 5 and it
was used for the four games that I
showed you just a minute ago it will not
be used for the next four games however
the game's built-in Benchmark so you're
not going to see the 1% minimum numbers
after Grand Theft Auto 5 those are all
going to be averages or averages
minimums and maximums most of the
built-in benchmarks are usually no more
than a minute or a minute and a half
long that's not really long enough for
the 1% number to really make much of a
difference you really need 5 or 10
minutes of gaml preferably long
in order to see a real split between 1%
and. 1% case in point I want you to look
at the numbers at the end of this
Benchmark run the 1% and. 1% minimum
numbers are very close to each other and
in fact we're within a couple of frames
per second of the actual true minimum I
did check when I was benchmarking the
reality is 1% numbers are pretty useless
when it comes to built-in benchmarking
you need longer runs you need live
gameplay for them to make a big
difference which is why you saw in the
four casual or Esports titles a much
larger difference between the 1% and. 1%
minimums because those were actually 10
15 minute long runs versus this which is
a minute maybe a minute and a half at
most now I mentioned this is a fairly
CPU bound test notice the CPU usage on
the RX 560s is nearly 100% there that's
what's actually holding back the
performance of the rx560 here we are at
the results if you want better frame
rates in this you actually need more
more CPU more graphics card wouldn't
make that much difference unless you
increase the resolution or increase the
detail setting look at the rx550 down at
the bottom we averaged 59 frames per
second we averaged anywhere between 74
to 78 frames per second on the various
RX 560s notice how close they all are to
each other we are primarily limited by
that ryzen 3 1300x CPU want more
performance a ryzen 5 1500x or a
5600 would produce a larger spread
between the numbers now I understand why
am I testing a CPU bound game on a CPU
limiting the game when we're comparing
graphics cards I am showing you that it
doesn't always matter which one you buy
because sometimes it actually matters
what your CPU is you'll see a bigger
split on the next four games because
they're not CPU bound this is the only
one I'm showing you that's really CPU
bound today moving on from Grand Theft
Auto 5 let's take a look at Tomb Raider
the 20 2013 reboot of the series now
this game is now 4 years old but I'm
including it to show you that you can
play AAA gaming titles at Ultra detail
without any problem on a $100 graphics
card today if you're willing to go back
three four or five years while Call of
Duty infinite Warfare is not necessarily
going to run at maximum detail Black Ops
3 and Black Ops 2 probably will
Battlefield 1 is absolutely not going to
run at Ultra detail but Battlefield 3
would yes I know those are kind of
backwards in number but it was
Battlefield 3 then Battlefield 4 then
Battlefield Hardline and then back to
Battlefield 1 now we'll be getting a new
Battlefield game in the fall of 2017 as
far as I know and we'll have to take a
look at that when it comes but this game
is 4 years old we are in fact playing at
Ultra detail look at our frame rate very
impressive now because this is a fairly
basic built-in Benchmark it's just one
scene it's entirely possible there would
be portions of the game that don't play
play this well easy solution run it high
instead of ultra for those sections we
just transition to the other four cards
you can see the difference now the vram
usage requirements in a 3 or four year-
old game are virtually non-existent we
are not even at 1 gab of vram because 1
Gigabyte was even a lot back then there
were cards four five six years ago that
even didn't even have that much vram so
games had to be able to run in far less
vram it's only in the past year or two
that games have really stepped up their
vram usages so a 2 GB rx560 is plenty
for an older game and frankly the
rx550 if you turn the detail down to
high would still perform pretty well I
mentioned this before I will mention
this again if you have a 3 four five or
even sixy year old Intel i5 processor
even an i5
2400 and you can put an rx560 in it
you'll get similar performance to what
you're seeing in this video now an i5
2400 is not really as fast as a Ry 3300x
but it's in the ballpark and we are not
at all CPU Bound in most of these games
we were in Grand Theft AO 5 but we're
certainly not here looking at the
results the three cards that do not use
a six pin PCI Express power connector
are the slowest the power color the
assus dual fan and the MSI Arrow ITX
those three cards 68 72 and 72 frames
per second do not use a six pin PCI
Express power connector the Vision Tech
the two sapphire pulses and the gigabyte
do they come clocked higher out of the
box from the factory they have more
potential overclocking because they can
draw up to 75 Watts from that six pin
connector and 75 Watts from the PCI
Express slot on the motherboard whereas
the three slower cards don't have that
option you furthermore now see how much
slower the rx550 really is 44 frames per
second average versus say 78 frames per
second on the sapphire pulse now you can
certainly turn the detail down in this
older game and it will run better on
that but this shows you that while the
560s aren't double the performance of
the 550 they are more than 50% faster it
really is a dramatic step up if you want
to play games I strongly recommend a 560
over a 550 now Tomb Raider came out in
2013 what about it squel rise of the
Tomb Raider which came out on the PC at
the beginning of 2016 now this game is a
year and a half old but it re recently
got a patch for directx12 which we are
running in here you can see the D3 D12
on each of the MSI After Burner numbers
and it also recently got a ryzen
performance patch a number of games have
been either patched or adjusted for the
ryzen CPUs and continue to get
improvements to direct X12 one of the
benefits to the AMD cards versus the
Nvidia cards at least in the current
generation is AMD generally tends to
scale with the rect X12 a little bit
better than Nvidia does it is not a
large difference but hey 5% % 10% more
performance is always nice when you can
get it now we are running on the first
four cards here Vision Tech powercolor
MSI and then the assus card of these
only the vision Tech in the upper
leftand corner has the six pin PCI
Express power connector and as you can
see it's the fastest card here this is
going to be similar in terms of the
spread of the previous results the cards
with the six pin PCI Express connector
are faster than the cards without them
it's not a huge difference and if you
have a system that simply cannot
accommodate a card that needs one you
certainly will get acceptable
performance on the three cards I'm
showing you here that don't have it but
if you can take it it's definitely worth
it because it does give you extra
performance essentially for free because
the cards with the six pin connector do
not generally cost more than the ones
without it now moving on to the second
set of four cards you will notice that
the vram usage is way below 2 GB in most
of this so the 4 GB doesn't make a
difference we are playing at medium
detail preset we we could certainly turn
it up to high or very high but then the
performance would fall right through the
floor now at the end of this video I'm
actually going to show you ghost recon
wildlands at low medium and high detail
to demonstrate how we can get the vram
usage over 2 GB and how useless it is
because the performance isn't there but
that's a subject for later in the video
now here we are on the second scene of
this and you'll see that vram slowly
crank up but it's still not going to
pass 2 GB because we're at medium detail
notice that we are in the mid 40s in
terms of frame rate except for the rx550
down there which is down in the high 20s
which is why that's not principally a
gaming card it'll do it but that's
pretty slow all things considered we're
not maintaining 60 frames a second and
we are playing at medium now you can
lower this game to low detail but if you
do so the appearance changes
dramatically the difference between low
and medium in many games is quite large
so I want to show you in this game what
a compromise detail setting is you don't
have to accept presets you can go in and
change one or two things turn Shadows
off or or turn viewing distance down
depending upon the game and you can
often times get a 5 or 10 frame rate uh
frames per second Jump by just making
one or two small changes rather than
changing everything once again the three
cards without the six pin are the
slowest but not by much 49 52 and 52
frames per second average on the
powercolor MSI and assus cards the ones
with a six pin connector are all about
the same performance 55 55 and 56 frames
per second average respectively please
note that you can run this test back to
back to back and you're going to get one
frame per second plus or minus these are
all within the margin of error
effectively the gigabyte Sapphire and
vision tech cards are all the actual
same performance you can see the minimum
frame rates are also very very close to
each other 30 31 32 33 Etc that rx550 37
frames per second average 24 frames per
second minimum even at low detail that
card is not really going to do 60 frames
per second it's not a gaming card and it
even has 4 gigs of vram why does it have
4 gigs of vram cuz that's what AMD sent
me now let's move on to the division
again medium detail preset now I did
actually try playing one Mission this is
the built-in Benchmark but I did try
playing one of the underground missions
the first downloadable content on one of
these cards completely totally playable
is it going to maintain over 60 frames
per second no it won't but let me tell
you it was very controllable if you're
not too picky about the whole 60 frames
a second maybe you're playing on a free
sync monitor with your AMD card that can
adjust the refresh rate of the monitor
to match the game's performance it'll be
very smooth and very playable would I
personally play it in this configuration
yes I would actually it was very very
nice no issues whatsoever now don't be
surprised when you see that again the
powercolor MSI and assus dual fan cards
are the slowest here you can see it
right on the screen that Vision Tech is
faster but I would like to point out
that that Vision Tech is one of the
louder cards here look at the fan speed
of the vision Tech almost 2500 rpm
versus 1300 RPM on the MSI Arrow the MSI
arrow is quieter than the vision Tech so
to get that little bit extra speed the
fan is louder the card is louder if you
do care about noise however I still
strongly recommend the sapphire pulse
cards or the gigabyte gaming if you can
swing it unlike in the Grand Theft Auto
5 Benchmark you can see here we're not
very CPU bound this game will use up to
four cores when you're actually playing
the game the built-in Benchmark does not
reflect that but having played this game
all the way through the entire story you
will see a higher CPU usage when you're
playing the game but it is completely
playable on a four core fourth thread
processor such as a ryzen 3 1200 1300x
or any of the Intel i5s from the past 6
years it really is fine vram usage is
not an issue we're under two gigs I
don't want to uh beat that point into
the ground but if you're playing games
even AAA games and you have an rx560
there's no benefit to getting the 4 gig
card the performance isn't there the the
the increase in performance is just not
justified for the extra money they cost
now I said earlier in this video that if
you can get the 4 gig card for $20 or
less more than the 2 gig card sure keep
in mind that that point was made mostly
for the people who go yeah but I'm not
going to sleep at night getting the two
gig card I'm too worried about the
future I want the 4 gig card for peace
of mind fair enough if it would bother
you if you would buy the 2 gig card and
just it would gnaw at you and you'd go
oh I'm worried about it oh is it going
to be a problem fine get the 4 gig card
just don't pay too much for it because
ultimately at the end of the day it
isn't going to make any real difference
to Performance and once again taking a
look at the rx550 down in the bottom
right hand corner of the screen and you
can see why that's not necessarily me
meant to be a gaming card for $ 20 to
$30 less it's nearly half the
performance not quite I mean it has half
the compute power but half the compute
power does not actually get rid of half
of your performance but it's anywhere
between 30 to 40% slower and that
definitely makes a difference we are
currently getting 55 frames per second
on the sapphire pulses and we're getting
33 frames per second on that
rx550 now as I said before we're using
the game's built-in Benchmark the
built-in Benchmark to the division does
not provide Max maximums and minimums so
all we have here are the averages but it
is very smooth 55 or 56 frames per
second on the cards with the six pin
power connector 49 to 52 frames per
second on the cards without it way down
at 34 frames per second on that rx550
and I think that's pretty much all there
is to say about that so we'll jump
straight into the Ghost Recon test now
this is all eight cards at low detail I
will separately in just a minute show
you medium and high on the two sapphire
cards now I did think about displaying
this differently where I could put all
eight cards on the screen at once maybe
just showing you half of each screen
there's actually physically room on the
screen if I split them again and showed
you the top half of each run I could put
all eight cards with all eight sets of
MSI After Burner numbers on the screen
at one time it would shorten the video
I'm sure somebody's bound to say Lord
this is a long video we have eight cards
we have nine games tested we have
multiple detail settings and a lot of
charts and commentary it's why the video
is so long but my goal here is to make a
complete and comprehensive video that
basically covers the subject front to
back furthermore if I were to double up
the screen while it would shorten the
video you wouldn't be able to see all of
the tests because you you'd be missing
half of the screenshot by putting this
in a quad configuration you can still
actually see the frame rate The
Benchmark the detail Etc let me know in
the comments below if you like this
where you see four cards and then four
more more cards separately or if you
actually would rather just have all
eight cards on the screen at one time
split across horizontally each one so
all you really see are the MSI After
Burner numbers here's the other question
how much do you really want to see the
live recording that you're watching
right now do you really just want to see
maybe one and then some Benchmark charts
or do you appreciate this this took
hours to put together um I've got about
3 days of work into this video total one
full day of that work was editing
putting together all these Benchmark
tests into the grid and putting up the
icons and labels and everything else
takes longer than you might think or at
least it takes me longer anyway so
here's the results low detail we had a
low of 51 frames per second average on
the powercolor card we had a maximum of
57 on the sapphire pulse gigabyte gaming
and vision tech cards you can see the
minimums and maximums there as well once
again the rx550 well it's here to
provide a compar comparison and to and
to show you why I recommend the rx560 so
much now I've said before that the rx560
is not really meant to be a AAA gaming
card it'll do it and I've shown you here
in this video that it will do it if
you're flexible with detail settings but
what happens if low is not acceptable if
you want medium or high detail well
let's take a look at that shall we now
here we have averages in the ' 50s and
minimums in the 30s what happens if we
go to medium and high detail on the top
of the screen you'll see the the
sapphire 2 GB card medium and high on
the bottom of the screen you'll see the
sapphire 4 GB card medium and high so
this allows you to compare what the
performance difference is on the same
card going horizontally between the
medium and high detail setting or you
can compare vertically going from the 2
GB to the 4 GB card notice something at
medium detail there's virtually no
difference at high detail there's a
little bit of a difference not much now
it's true if you look at the vram usage
at high detail we are at 2.8 GB of vram
whereas the 2 GB card can't handle that
obviously because it only has 2 GB of
vram but is the game playable we're down
at 30 frames per second it is pretty
rough All Things Considered first let's
talk about the medium detail results 40
and 41 frames per second average between
the 2 and the 4 GB card they're
essentially the same performance jumping
to medium only kicks it to about 2.2 2.3
GB of usage this is not impeding the
performance at high detail there is a
little bit of a difference how much
about 10% give or take we jump from 34
frames per second to 37 frames per
second that's a whole 3 frames per
second difference the vram does make a
small difference the minimum frame rate
on the high detail setting between the
two cards is 24 and 27 frames per second
again 3 frames per second same at the
maximum however is this game playable at
High detail on either of these cards I
would submit that it's not now I fully
understand some people would say I don't
care about 60 frames a second I'm fine
with 30 but keep in mind that the game
wasn't necessarily designed to run at 30
and you may run into input or frame
pacing lag issues this is also just the
games built-in Benchmark having played
this game extensively let me tell you
those minimums would not hold in the
game you will see performance numbers in
the teens at high detail on either of
these cards it simply doesn't have the
compute performance to run this game at
high detail you really need an RX 570 or
580 to do it so while the 4 GB helps it
doesn't help as much as I think a lot of
people suspect that it does the increase
in vram usage does hold back the 2 GB
card but it does not quote fall off a
cliff in performance as I have seen it
written numerous times where people say
well once you run out of vram your
performance just gets cut in half and
it's terrible I don't think three frames
per second difference is cut in half it
is different but not much and so there
you have it eight cards compared nine
games benchmarked what an amazing set of
performance the amount of power that you
get for about $1 to $120 these days is
incredible now my personal opinion the
best card up here if you have a six pin
PCI Express power connector is the
sapphire pulse it's a very nice card my
second choice personally would be the
gigabyte uh dual fan card but these
cards require a six pin connector if you
don't have room for a six pin connector
but you do have room for a dual fan card
get the assus card if you need something
smaller the MSI Arrow would be my next
favorite Choice followed by the vision
Tech as you saw from the performance
numbers that power color is by far the
slowest card here now it's true that you
can manually overclock cards but to be
honest its performance was a little bit
disappointing what about the rx550 well
as you saw from the benchmarks yeah it's
not really a gaming card it will do it
but that's not really what it's here for
it's a home theater PC card like this
video if you like it share it with your
friends if you loved it remember to
subscribe to my Channel with that big
huge red button directly below the video
questions and comments below the video
and as always please check out the links
in the video description links to Amazon
and New Egg for all these cards will be
down there please check prices buy it
where it makes the most sense to you and
do use those links when you're shopping
at Amazon and new eg it really does make
a difference links to my other reviews
My 500 series launch video my rx550
independent review will also be down
there as well thank you so much for
watching I will see you next time